The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resource for free.
To make a donation you or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's get started
with the second
lecture for today.
So I guess one thing multicores
did, is really
shatter this nice view of
writing in your programs and
hardwares to take care of,
giving you performance.
So hardware just kind of
completely gave that up.
But so what you're doing in this
class, is you're trying
to do it by yourself.
Give all the responsibility
back to the program.
And you realize as you go,
it's a much harder job.
I mean, this is not simple
programming.
So you need to have, you don't
have MIT class students on
every company to do this, so we
need to have some kind of
middle ground.
And so some of the stuff we have
been doing is trying to
figure out are there
any middle ground.
Can you actually take some of
that load away from the user
into things like languages
and compilers.
So we will talk about
some of those.
So right now we are kind of
switching from directly doing
what's necessary, to do the
Cell project into going
breadth So this lecture, and
then we will sit back and do a
little bit of debugging and
performance work and that will
be directly helpful.
And then next week we'll have
lots of guest lectures to kind
of give you breadth in there.
So you'll understand no just
Cell programming but parallel
programming and parallel
processing, what the world is
like beyond that.
So today we're going to have
Bill talk about streams.
BILL THIES: OK very good.
So my name is Bill Thies.
I'm a graduate student working
with Saman and Roderick, and
others here.
And I'll talk about the
StreamIt language.
So why do we need a new
programming language?
Well we think that languages
haven't kept up with the
architectures.
So one way to look at this is
that if you look back at
previous languages, look at C
with von-Neumann machine.
Now I grew up in rural
Pennsylvania not too far from
Amish Country.
And so to me these go together
just like a horse and buggy.
OK they're perfectly made
for each other.
They basically go at
the same rate.
Everything is fine.
But the problem is, in comes
the modern architecture.
OK this is an F-16.
you have a lot more that you can
do with it then, then with
the horse and buggy.
So how do you program these
new architectures?
Well architecture makers these
days are basically faced with
a really hard choice.
On the one hand, you could get a
really cool architecture and
develop an ad hoc programming
technique where you're really
just leaving it to the
programmer to do something
complicated to get
performance.
And unfortunately I
think that's the
route that they took.
I mean fortunately for the
industry, but unfortunately
for you, I think that's the
route they took with cell
which means all of you are
going to become basically
fighter pilots.
You have to learn how
to fly the plane.
You have to become an expert.
You're going to become the best
people at programming
these architectures.
And unfortunately the only other
option is to really bend
over backwards to support the
previous era of languages
like C and C .
And you can see what's coming
here, it's just hard to get
off the runway.
So you don't want
this situation.
Out of consideration for whoever
is in the buggy,
hopefully you'll
never take off.
So looking from a more academic
perspective, why do
we need a new language
right now?
So if you look back over the
past 30 years, I know you've
seen this graph before.
We were dealing with just
one core in the machine
for all this time.
And now we have this plethora
of multicores
coming across the board.
So how did we program
these old machines?
Well we had languages like C and
FORTRAN that really have a
lot of nice properties across
these architectures.
So it was portable,
high-performance, composable--
you could have really good
software development--
malleable, maintainable, all the
nice things you'd like to
see from a software engineering
perspective.
And really if you wrote a
program back in 1970, you
could keep it in C and have it
continue to leverage all the
new properties of machines
over the past 30 years.
So just one fine
out of the box.
And looking forward, that's
not going to be true.
So for example, we could
say that C was the
common machine language.
That's what we say for the
past 30 years, was common
across all the machines.
But now looking forward,
that's not
going to be true anymore.
Because you have to program
every core separately.
So what's the common machine
language for multicores?
We really think you need
something where you can write
a program once today, and have
it scale for the next 30 years
without having to modify
the program.
So what kind of language do you
need to get that kind of
performance?
Well let's look a little deeper
into this notion of a
common machine language.
So why did it work so well
for the past 30 years?
Well on uniprocessors, things
like C and FORTRAN fran really
encapsulated the common
properties.
So things like a single flow of
control in the machine, a
single memory image, are both
properties of the language.
But they also hid certain
properties from the
programmer.
So they hid the things that
were different between one
machine and another.
So for example, the register
file, the ISA, the functional
units and so on.
These things could change from
one architecture to another.
And you didn't have to change
your program because those
aspects weren't in the
programming language.
So that's why these languages
were succeeding.
And what do we need to succeed
in the multicore era from a
language perspective?
Well you need to encapsulate the
common properties again.
And this time it's multiple
flows of control that you have
for all the different cores, and
multiple local memories.
There's no more monolithic
memory anymore, that everyone
can read and write to.
Also you need to hide
some of the
differences between the machines.
So some cores have different
capabilities.
On cell there's a heterogeneous
system between
the STEs and the PPE.
Different communication models
on different architectures,
different synchronization
models.
So whatever common machine
language we come up with,
we'll have to keep these
things hidden from the
programmer.
Now a lot of different
researchers are taking
different tacts for how you want
to invent the next common
machine language.
And the thrust that we're really
excited about is this
notion of streaming.
So what is a stream program?
Well if you look at a lot of the
high-performance systems
today-- including Powerpoint
which is running this awesome
animation--
you can basically see that
they're based around some
stream of data.
So audio, video, like HDTV,
video editing, graphic stuff.
I think actually, a lot of the
projects in this class that I
looked at, would fit into
the streaming mold.
Things like the software
radio, array tracing, I
probably don't remember
them all.
But when I looked at them, they
all looked like they had
a streaming component
somewhere in there.
So what's special about a stream
program compared to
just a normal program?
Well they have a lot of
attractive properties.
If you look at their structure,
you can usually see
that the computation pattern
remains relatively constant
across the lifetime
of the program.
So they have some well-defined
units that are communicating
with each other.
And they continue that pattern
of communication throughout.
And this really exposes a lot
of opportunities for the
compiler to do some
optimizations that it couldn't
do on just an arbitrary general
purpose program.
And if you saw before, we have
basically all the types of
parallelism are really exposed
in a stream program.
There's the pipeline parallelism
between different
producers and consumers.
There's the task parallelism
basically going
from left to right.
And also data parallelism which
means that a single one
of these stages can sometimes be
split to apply to multiple
elements in the data stream.
So when you're thinking about
stream programming, there's a
lot of different ways
you can actually
represent the program.
So whenever you have a
programming model, you have to
answer these kinds
of questions.
For example do the senders and
the receivers block when they
try to communicate?
How much buffering is allowed?
Is the computation
deterministic?
What kind of model do
you have in there?
Can you avoid deadlock?
Questions like these, and we
could spend a whole lecture
answering these questions,
putting them in different
categories.
But what I want to just to do,
just to give you a feel is
touch on kind of three of the
major models that you might
see come up in different kinds
of programming models.
And I'll just touch Kahn process
networks, synchronous
dataflow, and communicating
sequential processes, or CSP.
So just one slide
on these models.
So let's compare them
a little bit.
First there's the Kahn
process networks.
So this is kind of the
simplest model.
It's very intuitive.
You just have different
processes that are
communicating over FIFOs.
And the FIFO size is
conceptually unbounded.
So to a first approximation,
it's kind of like a Unix pipe.
These processes can just read
from the input, and they can
push onto their outputs
without blocking.
But if they try to read from an
input they do block until
an input is available.
And the interesting thing is
that the communication pattern
can actually be dependent
on the data.
So for example I could pop an
index off of one channel, and
then use that index to determine
which other channel
I'll read from on the
next time time step.
But at the same time it
is deterministic.
So for a given series of input
values on the stream, I'll
always have the same
communication pattern that I'm
trying from the other input.
So if it's a deterministic
model, that's a nice property.
Let's see, what else
to say here?
There's actually a few recent
ventures that are using Kahn
process networks.
So there's commercial interest.
For example Ambric
is a startup that I think will
be based on a Kahn process
network for the programming
model.
Looking at another model called
synchronous dataflow,
this is actually what we use
in the StreamIt system.
And compared to Kahn
process networks,
it's kind of a subset.
It's a little bit more
restrictive.
So if you look at the space
of all possible program
behaviors, Kahn process networks
are a pretty big
piece of the space.
And then synchronous dataflow
is kind of a subset of that
space where you know more
about the communication
pattern at compile time.
So for example, in synchronous
dataflow, the programmer
actually declares how many items
it will consume from
each of its in put channels
on a given execution step.
So there's no more data
dependence regarding the
communication pattern.
It'll always input some items
from some of the channels and
produce some number of items
to other channels.
And this is a really nice
properties because it lets the
compiler do to scheduling
for you.
So the compiling can see who's
communicating to who and
exactly what pattern.
And it can statically interleave
the filters to
guarantee that everyone has
enough data to complete their
computation.
So there's a lot of interesting
optimizations you
can do here.
That's why it's very attractive
for StreamIt.
And you can statically guarantee
freedom from
deadlock, which is a nice
property to have.
The last one I want to touch on
is communicating sequential
processes or CSP.
And in the space of program
behaviors, it's kind of an
overlapping that from Kahn
processing networks, and adds
a few new semantic behaviors.
So the buffering model is
basically rendezvous
communication now.
So there's no bothering
in the system.
Basically anytime you send a
value to another process, you
have to block and wait until
that process will actually
receive that value from you.
So everyone is rendevouzing at
every communication step.
In addition to that, they
have some sophisticated
synchronization primitives.
So you can for example, discuss
alternative behaviors
that you have. You can either
one thing or another which
will introduce the
nondeterminism in the model.
Which could be a good or a bad
thing depending on the program
you're trying to express.
And pretty much the most
well-known encapsulation of
CSP is this occam programming
language invented
quite a while ago.
And some people are still
using that today.
Any questions on the
model computations?
OK.
So now let me get into
what StreamIt is.
So StreamIt is a
great language.
It's a high-level
architecture-independent language.
Oh question the back.
AUDIENCE: With the CSP I'm
trying to understand exactly
what that means or how
it's different.
Is basically what's it's saying
is you have a bunch
processes and they can send
messages to each other.
BILL THIES: So all these models
have that property.
AUDIENCE: They all
fit into that.
But it seems like from your
explanation of CSP, that that
was just sort of the essence
of CSP is it more specific?
BILL THIES: So CSP is usually
associated with rendezvous
communication.
That's the side of programs
that fit inside
Kahn process networks.
It's any communicating model
where you basically have no
buffering between
the processes.
Now the piece that sits outside
is usually lumped with
CSP, or especially with occam
They have a set a primitives
that are richer in terms
of synchronization.
So for example, you can have
guards on your communication.
Don't execute this consumption
from this channel until I see
a certain value.
So there's some more rich
semantics there.
And so that's the things that
are usually outside.
They're outside the
other models.
Does that make sense?
Other questions?
OK so StreamIt.
OK so StreamIt is
architecture-independent.
It's basically a really nice
syntactic model for
interfacing with these lower
level models of computation
for streaming.
And really we have two goals
in the StreamIt project.
And the first is from the
programmer's side.
So we want to improve the
programmer's life when you're
writing a parallel program.
We want to make it easier for
you to write a parallel
program then you would have to
do in C or a language like
Java, or any other language
that you know.
And at the same time, we want
scalable and portable
performance across
the multicores.
So an interesting thing these
days is you'll find, is it's
often very hard a tempt the
programmer to switch to your
favorite language based
solely on performance.
Or at least this has been the
story in the past. It may
change, looking forward.
Because it's a lot harder to
get performance these days.
But usually you have to offer
them some other carrot to get
them on board.
And you know the carrot here
is that it's really nice to
program in.
It's fun to program in.
It's beautiful.
It's a lot easier to program and
stream it then it would be
in something like C or Java
for a certain class of
programs. So that's how we get
them on board, and then we
also provide the performance.
We're mostly based on the
synchronous in dataflow model.
In that when there are static
communication patterns, we
leverage that from the
compiler side.
So I'll also tell you about some
dynamic extensions that
we have, that is the much richer
model of communication.
So what have we been doing
in the Streamit Project?
We have kind of a dual thrust
within our group building on
this language.
So the first thrust is from
the programmability side,
looking at applications and
programmability What can we
fit into the streaming model?
And we're also really pushing
the optimizations.
So what can you do from both a
domain specific optimization
standpoint, as kind of emulating
a DSP engineer or a
signal processing expert
in the design flow.
And also architecture specific
optimizations.
So we've been compiling for a
lot of parallel machines.
And we were hoping we could
have a full system for you
guys, this IEP, so you could
write it then stream it and
then hit the button.
And it would work the whole
way down to cell.
Unfortunately we're not
quite there yet.
But we do have a pretty robust
compiler infrastructure.
And you can download this off
the web and play with it if
you want to.
One of our backends that we've
released so far actually does
go to a cluster of
workstations.
So it's kind of an MPI-like
version of C. It uses Pthreads
for the parallelism model.
And I mean, depending on what
kind of a hacker you are, you
actually might be able to lower
that down onto cell.
So some of the stuff you might
be able to use if you're have
some initiative in there.
And of course we'd be
willing to work with
you on this as well.
so we have lots optimizations
in the tool flow.
And actually Saman will spend
another lecture focusing on
the StreamIt compiler,
and how we get
performance out of the model.
OK, so let's just jump right in
and do the analog of Hello
World in StreamIt.
I'm going to kind of walk you
through the language and show
you the interesting pieces
from an intellectual
standpoint.
What's interesting about
a streaming model that
you can take away.
So instead of Hello World,
we have a counter.
Since we're dealing with stream
programs here, you're
not usually doing
text processing.
So how do you write counter?
Well there are two pieces
to the program.
The first is kind of the
interconnect between the
different components.
That's what we have up here.
We're saying the program is a
pipeline with two stages, it
has a source, and it
has a printer.
And then we can write
the source and
the printer as filters.
We call those basic building
blocks filters in Streamit.
So the source will just have
a variable x that it
initializes is zero.
And then we have a work
function which is
automatically called by our
runtime system every time
through the steady state.
So this work function well push
one item on to the output
channel, and it'll increment
the value afterward.
Whereas the intPrinter
at the bottom here,
will input one value.
And its work function here just
pops that value off the
input tape, and prints
it to the output.
Now how do we run this thing?
Well there's no main function
here like you
see in Hello World.
Is there comment?
Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: The two meanings of
push and two meanings of pop.
BILL THIES: Two meanings?
AUDIENCE: Push 1, 2, 3.
BILL THIES: Yeah, yeah.
So the first push here is just
declaring that this work
function will push one item
to the output tape.
So this is the synchronous
dataflow aspect.
Were associating an output rate
with this work function.
So that's a declaration here.
Whereas this push is just
actually executing the push
onto the output.
So how do we run this thing?
Well we compile it with a
StreamIt compiler, store C
into a binary.
And then when we run, we run
for a given number of
iterations.
So you don't just
call it once.
Our model is that this is a
continuous stream of data
going through the program.
And so when you run it, you
run it for some number of
iterations, or basically input
or output items, is what
you're running it for.
So if you run this for four
iterations, it would
print in the 033.
So we can leverage this
steady flow of data.
Yeah Amir?
AUDIENCE: 1, 2, 3, 4, pushing
X plus plus .
BILL THIES: I think
the plus, plus is
executed after the push.
AUDIENCE: Push plus plus?
BILL THIES: So it
starts at zero.
So I think a PostFix expression
executes after the
actual obsession.
Yeah.
Other questions?
OK so let's step up a
level and look at
what we have in StreamIt.
So the first question is, how
do you represent this
connectivity between different
building blocks?
How do you represent streams?
And if you look at traditional
programming models, kind of
the conventional wisdom
is that a stream
program is a graph.
You have different
nodes that are
communicating to each other.
And graphs are actually kind
of hard to analyze.
They're hard to represent.
They're a little
but confusing.
So the approach we decided to
take in StreamIt is one of a
structured computation graph.
So instead of having arbitrary
inner connections between the
stages, we have a higher
hierarchical description in
which every individual stage
has a single input and a
single output.
And you can compose these
together into
higher level stages.
Of course there's some pages
that do split and join with
multiple inputs.
We'll get to that.
So the analog here is kind of
ah analogous to structured
control flow, in your favorite
imperative programming language.
Of course there was a day when
everyone used goto statements
instead of having structure
control flow.
We've got a fan of goto
statements in the audience?
OK, I'll get to you later.
But the problem was, it's really
hard to understand the
program that's jumping all over
the place because there's
no local reasoning you can have.
You know you're jumping
to this location, you're coming
back a different way.
It's hard to reason about
program components.
So when people went to
structured control flow,
there's just if else, four
loop statements.
Those are the two basic
constructs.
You can basically express all
kinds of computation in those
simple primitives.
And things got a lot simpler.
And you know people objected
at one point even.
You know what about a
finite-state machine?
Don't you need goto statements
for a finite-state machine,
going from one state
to another another.
And now everyone writes in FSM
with a really simple idiom.
You usually have a while loop
around a case statement.
Right, you have a
dispatch loop.
So and now whenever you see
that pattern you can
recognize, oh there's a
finite-state machine.
It's not just at set of gotos.
It's a finite-state machine.
So we think there are
similar idioms in
the streaming domain.
And that's kind of the direction
we're pushing from a
design standpoint.
So what are our structures
that we have?
Well here are our structured
streams. At the
base we have a filter.
That's just the programmable
unit like I showed you.
We have a pipeline, which just
connects one stream to another
in a sequence.
So this gives you pipeline
parallelism.
There's a splitjoin where you
have explicit parallelism in
the stream.
So I'll talk about what these
splitters and joiners can do.
It's basically a predefined
pattern of scattering data to
some child streams, and then
gathering that data back into
a single stream.
So the whole construct still
remains single input and
single output.
Likewise a feedback loop is
just a simple way to put a
loop in your stream.
And of course these
are hierarchical.
So all of these green boxes
can be any of the three
constructs.
So that's how you can have these
hierarchical graphs.
And again, since everything is
single-input single-output,
you can really mix and match.
You know choose your favorite
components, and they'll always
fit together.
You don't need to stitch
multiple connections.
So let's dive inside one
of these filters now.
And I gave you a feel for how
they look before, but here's a
little more detail.
So how do we program
the filter?
Well a filter just transforms
one stream
into another stream.
And here it's transforming a
stream of floating-point
numbers into another
floating-point number stream.
I can take some parameters
at the top.
These actually fixed at compile
time in our model,
which allows the compiler to
really specialize the filters
code depending on the context
in which it's being used.
So for example here, we're
inputting N in a frequency.
And then we have two stages
of execution.
At initialization time-- this
runs one at the beginning of
the whole program-- we can
calculate some weights for
example, from the frequency.
And we can store those weights
as a local variable.
So you can think of this kind
of like a Java class.
You can have some member
variables.
You can retains state from one
execution to the next.
The work function
is the closest
thing to the main function.
This is called repeatedly
in the steady state.
And here are the IO rates
of the work function.
This filter actually peaks at
some data items. That means
that it inspects more items on
the input channel than it
actually consumes on
every iteration.
So we'll look at N input items,
and we'll push one new
item onto the output and pop one
item from the input tape
every time we execute.
So here we have a sliding
window computation.
It means the next time through,
we'll just slide this
window up by one and inspect
the next N items
on the input tape.
And inside the work function
you can have pretty much
general purpose code.
Right now we just allow pointers
and a few other
things to keep things simple.
But the idea is this is general
purpose imperative
code inside the work function.
Now what's nice about this
representations of a filter is
for one thing is this
peak function.
So what we really have is a
nice representation of the
data pattern, that you're
reading the data
on the input channel.
And if you look at this for
example in a language like C,
it's a lot messier.
So usually when you're doing
buffer management, you have to
do some modulo operations.
You have to keep a circular
buffer of your live data.
And increase you know, a head or
tail pointer and mod around
the side with some kind
of modulo operation.
And for a compiler, this
is a real nightmare.
Because modulo operations
are kind of the the
worst thing to analyze.
You can't see what it's actually
trying to read.
And if you want to map this
buffer to a network or to a
combined communication with some
other actor or filter in
the graph, it's pretty
much impossible.
So here is we're exposing that
all to the compiler.
And you'll see how that
can make a difference.
And also it's just a lot
easier to program.
I mean, I don't like looking
at the code.
So I'm going to go to
the next slide.
OK, so how do we piece
things together?
Let's just build some higher
level components.
So here's a pipeline
of two components.
And we already saw a pipeline.
You can just add one component
after another.
And add just basically has the
effect of making a queue, and
just queueing up all of the
components that you added, and
connecting them one
after another.
So here we have a BandPastFilter
by connecting a
LowPassFilter and feeding it's
output into a HighPassFilter.
You end up with a
BandPassFilter.
OK what about a splitjoin?
How do we make those?
So a splitjoin has an add
statement as well.
And here we're adding components
in a loop.
So what this means is now when
we say add, we're actually
adding from left to right.
So instead of going top to down,
we're adding from left
to right across the splitjoin.
And we can actually
do that in a loop.
So here we're intPrinting a
parameter N. And depending on
that value, we'll add N
BandPassFilters to this splitjoin.
So it's kind of cool, right?
Because you can input a
parameter, and that parameter
actually affects the structure
of your graph.
So this graph is unrolled at
compiled time by our compiler,
constructing a big sequence
of computations.
And it can resolve the structure
and communication
pattern in that graph, and then
map it to the underlying
substrate when we compile.
Also to notice here are the
splitter and the joiner.
So we have a predefined set
of splitter and joiners.
I'll go into more
detail later.
But here we're just duplicating
the data to every
one of these parallel
components, and then doing a
round-robin join pattern where
we bring them back together
into a single output stream.
And if you want to do an
equalizer, you basically need
an adder at the bottom
to add the
different components together.
And another thing you can notice
here is that we have
some inlining going on.
So we actually embedded this
splitjoin inside a higher
level pipeline.
So what this does is it prevents
you from having to
name every component
of your stream.
You can have a single stream
definition with lots of nested
components.
And the natural extension is,
you can basically scale-up to
basically the natural size of
a procedure, just like you
would in an imperative
language.
And here is for example, an FM
radio where we have a few
inline components.
And the interesting thing here
is that there's a pretty good
correspondence between the
lines of the text and the
actual structure of the graph.
And that's something that's
hard to find in
an imperative language.
I mean if you want to for
example, stitch nodes together
with edges, it's often very
hard to visualize the
resulting structure of the graph
that you have. But here
if you just go through the
program, you can see that the
AtoD component goes right over
to the AtoD, the demodulator
to the demodulator, and so on.
And even for the parallel
components, you can kind of
piece them together.
so that's kind of how we think
of building programs. Any
questions so far?
OK so this is kind of
how you go about
programming in StreamIt.
But programming is kind of a
chug n' plug activity right?
Nobody wants to be
a code monkey.
The reason we're all here is to
see what's beautiful about
this programming model.
Right?
Don Knuth said this, a famous
computer scientist from
Stanford during his Turing
Award Lecture you know,
"Some programs are
elegant, some are
exquisite, some are sparkling.
My claim is that it is possible
to write grand
programs, noble programs, truly
magnificent ones!" Right.
We want the best programs
possible.
It's not just about
making it work.
We want really beautiful
programs. So what's beautiful
about the streaming domain?
What can you go away with and
say wow, that was a really
beautiful expression
of the computation.
Well for me I think one of the
interesting things here is the
splitjoin contruct.
Splitjoins can really
be beautiful.
You know some mornings I just
wake up and I'm like, oh I'm
so glad I live in a world
with splitjoins.
You know?
And and now splitjoins will
be part of your world.
You can say this tomorrow.
This is just wonderful.
So OK, what do we having in
the splitjoin constructs?
You can duplicate data.
You can do a round-robin
communication pattern from one
to another, or round-robin
join.
Now the duplicate is
pretty simple.
You just take the input
stream and duplicate
it to all the children.
No problem.
What do you do for
a round-robin?
Well you path N items from the
input to a given child.
So for example, if N is 1, we'll
just distribute one at a
time to the child streams. And
you get a pattern like this, a
round-robin just going across.
And you can do the same thing
on the joiner side.
Let's say you're joining
with a factor of one.
You're just reading from the
children and putting them into
a single stream.
OK so the pretty colorful, but
nothing too fancy yet.
Let's consider a different
round-robin factor.
So a round-robin of 2 means that
we peel off 2 items from
the input, and pass those items
to the first output.
OK there actually is going
to be a quiz on this.
So ask questions of this
doesn't make sense.
OK pass the next 2 items, and 2
items round-robin like that.
And you can actually
have nonuniform
weights if you want to.
So on the right let's
say we're doing
round-robin 1, 2, 3.
That means we pass 1 item from
the first stream, 2 items from
the next stream, and then 3
items from the third stream.
OK, pretty simple.
We're just doing 1, 2,
and 3, and so on.
Does that make sense?
I'm going to build on this
so any questions?
OK this was colorful but this
totally beautiful yet.
So what's beautiful
about this?
well let's see how you might
write a matrix transpose.
OK, something you guys have
probably all written at one
point in your life is
transposing a matrix.
Let's say this matrix has M
rows, and it has N columns
going across.
And we're starting with a
representation in which the
stream is basically, I think
this is row major order.
The first thing that you're
doing is going across the rows
before you're going to the
next the next row.
I'm sorry you're going across
the columns, and then down to
the next row.
So it's zigzagging like this.
And you want to pass through
a transpose, so you
zigzag the other way.
You do the first column,
up, and then the next
column, and so on.
And this comes up a lot
in a stream program.
So it turns out you can
represent this as a splitjoin.
Oh that's not good.
Just in my moment in
glory as well.
OK, yeah slides.
You can download slides.
Actually I can do this
on the board.
This is the thinking
part anyway.
Yeah, could you just
bring up GMail?
I have a backup on GMail.
Can we focus on the board?
So this is going to be a
little exercise anyway.
OK, here's what we had.
We had M, M rows, N columns.
We started with an interleaving
like this.
Right, and we want to
go into a splitjoin.
And this will be a round-robin
construct.
And what I want you to do is
fill in the round-robin
weight, and also the number of
the streams. And you can have
a round-robin at the bottom.
And when it comes out,
you want the opposite
interleaving.
This is M and N.
OK so there are 3 unknowns here,
what you're doing the
round-robin by-- can you guys
see that over there--
how many parallel streams there
are, and what you're
joining the round-robin by.
Ok so I'm going to give you a
minute to think about this.
Try to think about this.
See if you can figure out what
these constants are.
You just basically want to read
from this data in a row
major pattern, M rows and N
columns, and end up with
something that's column major.
What are the values
for the constant?
Does it makes sense?
Ask a question if it
doesn't make sense.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So we assume that
values are going to, based on
the line that you drew, across
it, tests like a stream line?
BILL THIES: Right,
right, right.
So those values are coming
down the stream.
You have a 1-dimensional
stream.
It's interleaved like this.
So you'll be reading
them like this.
And then you the output a
1-dimensional stream that is
threading the columns.
Does that make sense?
Somebody ask another question.
Yeah
AUDIENCE: So the actual matrix
transpose codes, it's my
understand that nobody actually
does it sequentially
like that because of
locality issues.
Instead it's broken
up into blocks.
BILL THIES: So there are
ways to optimize this.
AUDIENCE: And after you've sort
of serialized it, can you
then capture..
PROFESSOR: Guys,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
has a blocking segment.
So you can heirarchically
do that.
So, normally what happens is you
do the blocks and inside
the blocks, you can
do it again.
You can do it at two
levels, basically.
BILL THIES: Any hypotheses?
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: Is it N for first
one, M for the second one?
BILL THIES: OK, what
do we have
AUDIENCE: N for the first one,
and M for the second?
BILL THIES: N,M and
AUDIENCE: Same for the M?
BILL THIES: Same, M?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BILL THIES: OK OK, this
is a hypothesis.
Other hypotheses?
AUDIENCE: N, M, 1.
BILL THIES: OK, anyone else?
Any amendments?
AUDIENCE: How about 1, 1, 1?
BILL THIES: 1, 1, 1?
OK lottery is closing.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: !, M, M
BILL THIES: 1 M, M?
1, M, M, OK and last call?
OK I believe two of the ones
submitted are correct.
Is this and, yeah?
OK I think this, N, M, 1, works
and 1, N, M, works.
So let me explain the 1, N,
M, this is how I like
to think about it.
One way to think about this
is we just want to
move the whole matrix.
You doing OK, yeah?
OK we just want to
move the whole
matrix into this splitjoin.
So the way we can do that
is have M columns of the
splitjoin since we have N
columns of the matrix.
And what we'll do is we'll just
do a round-robin one at a
time, from the columns of
the matrix into the
columns of the splitjoin.
So we'll take the first element,
send it to the last,
next element, next column,
and so on.
So we get the whole matrix here,
Now I want to read it
out column-wise.
So we'll do a joiner of M. We'll
read M from the left
stream that'll read all M items
from the columns, send
it out, and then M items
in the next column, and
then send it out.
Does that make sense?
How many people understood
that?
All right,
So if you think about it, you
can also do it in M, N, 1.
That's basically, yeah,
it's very similar.
OK there we were.
And yes.
We can do 1, N, M. We basically
read the matrix
down, and then pull it
down into column.
And it's very easy to write
this as a transpose.
So we just have a transpose
filter in
which we're doing nothing.
No competition in the actual
rows or the actual contents of
the splitjoin.
And we just split the data by
1, have N different identity
filters, and then join it back
together by M. Any questions
about this?
An interesting way to
write a transpose.
OK so there's one more
opportunity to shine here.
And that's a little more
interesting permutation called
a bit-reversed ordering.
And so this comes up in an FFT
and another algorithm.
The permutation here, is that
we're taking the data
at the index n.
And let's say n has binary
digits b sub 0, b sub
1, up to b sub k.
And we want to rearrange that
data, so this data goes to a
different index with the
reversed bits of its index.
So if it was and index n before,
it ends up at b sub k
down to b sub 1, b sub 0.
So for example, let's
just look at
3-digit binary numbers.
If we have 0, 0, 0, this
is 1 input item.
We're reversing those digits,
you still get 0, 0, 0.
Item at index 1 will
be 0, 0, 1.
We want to reorder
that to index 4.
OK, 1, 0, 0, 0, 1, 0, stays the
same, 0 1, 1, goes to 1,
1, 0 shifts over.
And from there on,
it's symmetric.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
BILL THIES: Sorry?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
BILL THIES: OK.
So here I'm writing
the indices.
So I'm not writing the data.
So index 0, 1, 2, 3 up through
index 8., or index 7.
OK and on the bottom you have
indices 0 through 7.
So the data will actually be
moved, reordered like that.
Does that make sense?
It's a reordering of data.
Does this transformation
make sense?
Other questions?
OK, it turns out you can write
this as a splitjoin.
And you just need 3 different
weights for the round-robins.
OK round-robin with 1 weight
on the top here, and two
different round-robin weights
on the bottom.
And here I'm assuming you have 3
binary digits in your index.
So you're reordering
in groups to 8.
OK, so let me give you a second
to think about this.
What are the values
for these weights?
I'll give you a hint
in just a second,
or ask another question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
BILL THIES: So what we're doing
here, is we're exposing
the communication pattern.
That's the thing.
If you write this in an
imperative way, you end up
basically having your, you're
conflating basically the data
dependencies with the
reordering pattern.
So what I'm trying to convey
here, is how you can use the
streaming model to show how
you're sending data around.
Because when you're on an
architecture-like cell,
everything is about
the data motion.
You're taking data from one
place and you're trying to
efficiently get it to the
producers or the consumers.
And you really need to-- the
compiler needs to understand
the data motion.
And also, it's just another
way of writing it, which I
think it's actually easier to
understand once you see it.
It's a way to think about the
actual reordering from a
theoretical standpoint
Any wagers on this?
So what we to do, if you think
about the bit-reverse
ordering, what we want to do is
distribute the data by the
low-order bits.
And then gather the data
by the high-order bits.
So you want a fine-grained
parity when you're shuffling.
You can also do it the
other way around.
It's totally symmetrical.
But one way to think about it
is, you want a fine-grained
parity when you're distributing
data, and then a
course-grained when you're
coming together.
Anyone see it?
Give you ten more seconds.
Come on?
Yeah it is a little
bit tricky.
OK well let me explain
how it works.
So 1, 2, and 4.
Ok so what these round-robin 1
splitters do, is these are
basically the fine-grained
parities.
So OK, the first round-robin,
that will send all the even
bits to the left, and all the
odd values to the right.
Right, that's the lowest
order bit.
Because it's doing
every other one,
shuffling it left and right.
So this round-robin is seeing
only the even values.
Now it's going to split
them up based on who's
divisible by 4.
Now we'll go to the left
or go to the right.
This is basically shuffling in
the order of the bits, from
low-order bits to
high-order bits.
So these will be ordered in
terms of their low-order bits.
And now we just want to read
them out from left to right.
Just take the order that we made
with those round-robins,
and read them out from
left to right.
And since they have 8 values,
you can do that just by
chunking them up.
We'll read 2, 2, and then we'll
read these two, 2 and 2,
and now put all 8.
Does that make sense?
OK, so yes, it's a bit clever.
So I think it's a nice way
of thinking about what a
bit-reversed ordering means.
And you can write this in
a very general way.
You just have a recursive
bit-reversed
filter for N values.
And base case, you
only have 2.
So there's no reordering
to do when you when
you think about it.
So you're not doing
any computation.
Otherwise yo have a round-robin
split in half, and
then have a coarse-grain
joiner.
So, you get a structure
like this.
If you're, as you're building
up, just distributing and then
bringing back together in
a course-grained way.
OK.
Let's see how do I
don't do this?
OK so one thing to notice,
there's one more
example of a splitjoin.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
BILL THIES: OK so in general, at
the base of this hierarchy,
we could've added some other
filter to do some competition.
Identity just means we're
doing no computation.
It's a predefined filter
that just does nothing.
PROFESSOR: On complex data.
BILL THIES: On complex data.
Sorry this is a templated
filter.
So we're reordering
complex values.
And we're passing the
input to the output.
Amir?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
BILL THIES: In general the
language does not have support
for templates.
We only do it for these
base classes.
That's more of an implementation
detail.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
BILL THIES: Right now
there isn't, but
nothing fundamental there.
Yeah?
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: How did you know that
there are two filters
after that?
BILL THIES: Two filters,
sorry here?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
BILL THIES: OK.
OK.
So we have two add statements
between the
split and the join.
So that branches to two
parallel streams.
Is that your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How do you that theorem, that
there's not like three.
BILL THIES: So the compiler
will analyze
this, the compile time.
And it'll know these values of
N and propagate them down at
compile time.
So it'll basically symbolically
evaluate this
code, see there are two
branches, and you can unroll
this communication pattern.
AUDIENCE: I think another way of
thinking about it is, each
add statement essentially
adds another
branch in your splitjoin.
PROFESSOR: That is
another box.
BILL THIES: It's about to
get clear actually.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
BILL THIES: That's one way
to think about it, yeah.
Wait say again, counting?
AUDIENCE: A rating sort.
BILL THIES: A rating
sort, right.
OK, well is it sorting?
It's not really sorting.
AUDIENCE: Well it's not
really sorting.
BILL THIES: It's
a permutation.
AUDIENCE: Could you
do a rating sort?
BILL THIES: You could
do a rating sort.
So actually, what I want to show
next is how you can morph
this program into a merge sort
by changing only a few lines.
OK look carefully.
Don't blink.
OK there's merge sort.
So very similar pattern.
This is one of those idioms.
It's a recursive idiom with
splitjoins.
But now in the base case,
we have a sort.
So we would basically
branch down.
What we ended up with was
a sort in the base case.
We're just sorting
a few values.
And we call [? merge sort ?]
twice again, and
then we do a merge.
So instead of identity at the
base case here, we now have a
basic sorting routine.
And we merge those results
from both sides.
And the only thing I changed in
terms of the communication
rate, is to be more efficient
we just distributed data in
chuncks instead of doing a
fine-grained splitting.
Actually you do it however
you want in a merge sort.
But this is chunked up.
And let's just zoom in here.
This is how a merger sort
looks in StreamIt.
So we split the data two ways,
both directions, come
together, do a sort on both
sides, and then you merge.
And so by having the, you know
you can interleave pipelines
and splitjoins like this.
So you have these hierarchical
structures that are coming
back together.
Does this make sense?
OK.
I'm going to hold off on
messaging actually.
Let me see, what do
I want to cover?
OK let me actually
skip to the end.
Oh, I can show you this.
Yeah, I'm going to cut
short a little bit.
So here's how other programs
look written in StreamIt.
OK, you can have
a Bitonic sort.
OK so you see a lot of these
regular structures.
And the compiler can unroll
this and then
match it to the substrate.
This is how and FFT looks.
It's quite an ah elegant
implementation of an FFT.
It'd be good to go into
in more detail.
You can do things like block
matrix multiply.
You don't always have to have
column or row-wise ordering.
It's natural to split
things up like this.
We have a lot of DSP algorithms,
the filter bank,
FM radio with equalizer,
radar array front end.
Here's an MP3 decoder.
And let's see, I'm going to
skip this section and just
give you a taste for
the end here.
I'm skipping a hundred slides.
Yeah.
OK so if I give you a feel.
Our biggest program written
in StreamIt so far, is the
complete MPEG-2 encoder
and decoder.
So here is MPEG-2 decoder.
And I think you've seen
block diagrams of this
already in the class.
And so it's a pretty
natural expression.
You can really get a feel for
the high-level structure of
the algorithm mapping down.
And for example, here on the
top we're doing the spatial
decoding looking inside
each frame.
Whereas at the bottom we're
doing the temporal decoding
between two frames, the
motion compensation.
And one thing that I didn't have
a chance to mention, is
that we have a concept of
teleport messaging.
What this means is, I showed you
how the steady state flow
data goes between these
actors in the stream.
But sometimes you want to
control the stream as well.
For example, this is
a variable length
decoder at the top.
It's parsing the input data.
It might want to change how the
processing is happening
downstream.
For example, say that you have--
you know in this case
you have different picture
types coming in.
And you want to tell other
components to change their
processing based on a
non-local effect.
And that's hard to do if you
just want static data rates.
But what we have is this limited
notion of limited
dynamism, where you're basically
poking into somebody
else's stream.
And we let you do that
very precisely.
I don't have time to go into
the details, but you can
basically synchronize the
arrival of these messages with
the data that's also flowing
through the stream, And so in
this case, were sending through
the picture type.
And it really simplifies
the program code.
I didn't have time for details,
but why don't we put
in the slides anyway, if
you're interested.
And if you do a similar
communication pattern in C,
it's a little bit
of a nightmare.
You have all these different,
basically memory spaces,
different files.
And the control information
is basically going left
and right all over.
So this really helps both the
compiler and the programmer as
well in StreamIt.
So it's all implemented.
It's about 2,000 lines
of code in StreamIt.
Which is about 2/3 of the size
of the C code, taking into
account similar functionality
there.
And it's a pretty big program.
You can write 48 static streams.
And then we expand
that to more than 600
instantiated filters.
So this gives you a lot of
flexibility when you're trying
to get parallelism.
Question?
AUDIENCE: When a compiler
downloads all bytes?
BILL THIES: Oh the object
code, you mean.
OK, so right now our current
implementation, we duplicate a
lot of code.
So it end up being bigger
than it needs to be.
There's no reason for
us to do that.
That's kind of a-- we have
a research compiler
that make that easy.
AUDIENCE: So object-wise
, its not data.
BILL THIES: Object-wise we
still need to do that
comparison.
Yeah that's a good question.
Yeah.
Other questions?
OK so let me cut to the end.
OK, so we have the StreamIt
language.
And we think it really
preserves the program structure.
It's a new way of thinking about
how you orchestrate the
data reordering with the
splitjoins, showing you who is
communicating to who, and how
you can stitch together
different pieces in your
program development.
And again, really our goal is to
get this scalable multicore
performance.
But you can't get people
on board just on
a performance stat.
You need to show them a new
programming model that
actually makes their
lives easier.
So that's what we're
working on.
And thinks with listening.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL THIES: Any last
questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in the
anti-decoder, you have a lot
of computations size that were
not sequential streams. Like
for example, the output of the
distinct cosine transform is
not a stream of pixel, you are
going to have coefficients and
things like that.
Which are a logical
sort of chunk.
BILL THIES: Yes so depending
on the granularity of the
competition, you don't need to
pass individual values over
the stream.
For example, you can have a
stream that inputs the whole
array at a time.
And so we basically advocate
that if you have something
that course-grained, you should
be passing an array or
a macroblock, in the case of
MPEG, or a set of coefficients
in a structure.
So when you have coarse-grain
parallelism, you write your
program in a course-grained
way.
The fine-grained things
I showed for the bit
interleaving and so on, is
more for the fine-grained
programs. AUDIENCE:
Can you do both?
In the sense that can you stream
over an array, so it's
stream of stream, so to speak.
BILL THIES: So there's an
interesting multidimensional
problem there.
Right now we've taken a
1-dimensional approach.
So far it's basically the
programmer has to set an
iteration order, and end up with
a 1-dimensional stream
coming into and out
of every filter.
We're working on
extending that.
Yeah, but when you have
basically streams of
2-dimensional data, you like the
freedom to either iterate
basically in time or
in space, depending
on what you're doing.
And so I think that's more
of a research problem.
So far we're just been doing a
1-dimensional representation.
Yeah good point.
Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why did you decide on
this synchronous dataflow
model as opposed to something
more general?
BILL THIES: So our philosophy
has been that you want to
start with the most kind of
basic block of a stream
program, and optimize
it really well.
And then you can stitch
those together into
higher level blocks.
So we think of synchronous
dataflow as being kind of the
basic block of streaming.
You know what's coming in, you
know what's coming out.
And even if you have a more
general model, they'll be
pieces that fit under their
synchronous dataflow model.
And so we saw a lot
of optimizations
opportunities in there.
And really knowing those IO
rates can let you do a lot of
things that you can't do
in a general model.
So I wanted to get the simple
case right first. And actually
kind of our focus now is on
expanding, and how do you look
at the heterogeneous system, and
how do you optimize a more
dynamic system.
Yep.
Other questions?
OK.
Yes.
You can check out
our web page.
Yeah if you Google for
StreamIt, I'm sure
you can find it.
Yeah, we have a public
release.
Yes, send us any problems.
It's actually it's a good
test. We want to make sure
it works for everyone.
But I mean, we've had, you know,
hundreds of downloads.
There are a lot of people
using StreamIt.
It shouldn't break if
you download it.
Yeah.
OK good.
Thanks.